man everybody is on my ass about me  taking better care of myself I'm like  would my wife bought me a bicycle  thinking I might ride it it's for sale  and if you're looking for a bicycle as  the great deals got like 750 yards on it  it was a demo when I bought it it had  350 yards already on it but I put the  other 400 yards on there myself and if  you want to buy the bicycle just go to  my house in Atlanta and it's 400 yards  from there you never know what life's  gonna have in store for you but if you  had told me 10 years ago that today I  would have the same number a tour de  France was his Lance Armstrong  I wouldn't have believed it but here it  is - tie right now and I'm still  qualified to enter this year  [Applause]